i'm here with my dear old friend and my
absolute hero seth meyers and joining us
is uh the shirley temple king himself
and my other dear friend leo kelly
leo i understand you've created a
special beverage in honor of seth's book
yes thank you so much for having me and
it's great to meet you great to meet you
too
so i absolutely love the book that you
made i'm not scared you're scared so i
created a special drink it's in the
shirley temple universe it's called the
black bear e shirley temple inspired by
my favorite character in the book bear i
love it very very clever
all right leo show us how it's done so
you're going to take a glass put some
ice and now we're going to take some
black bear east seltzer that's right
add that in all right and then we're
going to take our black bear e syrup
okay and now let's just do it until you
think it's right not too dark but not
too light i really like that you're not
like bossy about it just do it until you
think it's right
and now let's add a squirt of lime juice
okay you can do as much as you want i
went i went big on the lime because i
love a little of that fresh citrus so
this is still in the shirley temple
universe and you know and as you know
shirley temples require cherries yes of
course so let's add a cherry or two okay
i'm gonna do two right i'm going for the
whole thing yeah and then is it cool to
just drink the cherry yeah oh
i like cherries oh that's all good sugar
yeah fresh cherry juice yeah so now
um
we'll add some actual the fruit black
bear ease yeah black grapes
genius i love it let's add uh as many as
you want i'm gonna add three again as
many as you want i love you guys it's
just this isn't like i've gone to
bartending school and they're way worse
than this
they were like very specific when now
when did you read the book uh i read the
book um i read it with my uh younger
brother and my sister last night and the
day before because that book you can
never never get sick of it's so much
adventure
and there's many different ways that you
can look at it there's many different
angles there's friendship there's
courage there's bravery and there's
adventure and i really like the
adventure part now i want to stress
something leo was not paid to say any of
that
but
but i am
i am going to slip him a little
something after the show
cheers
i'm regretting you haven't been with me
for this entire press tour thank you
leo i just love you so much i'm so glad
that i've been able to find you in this
world such a great partner in fact i'd
like to get your take on something now i
pulled up a few pictures because i need
some parent advice because i'm
i'm the bear here i'm a little afraid my
daughter frankie is turning eight uh
she's one of those kids that loves um
like death and cemeteries and asks about
the afterlife all the time and this is
the cake she wants all right
and i'd like to show you a series of
invitations um i like this is one option
she wants everyone to be we've come up
with the word spooky because death i
thought i was like i don't know how to
send that out to parents yeah no spooky
no i want a death theme i'm like i'm
scared as a parent to scare their
parents so that's one
option here's another this is kind of
more where she's at okay i like the
first one i'm just saying i really like
the first one and also in the monster
mash it never says anything about
halloween so at the party you could just
be blasting it all day
i love that and we want to make it a
costume party yes um yeah and uh but she
really wants everyone she's like i just
am worried if you say it's a costume
party people are going to come as
princesses i don't want any princesses i
only want death
i'm like how do i put that on an
invitation
dress code spooky costumes spooky yeah i
think it was a spooky costume oh and
before i go i have to ask you a few
questions let's do it so
when you were a kid what was your fear
and how did you overcome it
i was very afraid of going too fast in
anything for example when i would go
skiing my brother who's younger than me
would just race down the mountain and i
was very like sort of locked into the
snow plow position and it did take me a
long time to have the courage to get up
on stage in front of people which is one
day leo you will be able to get up in
front of people oh son of a gun you're
already doing it leo you are way ahead
of where i was
the perfect question leo
um as always my dear partner in crime
leo kelly thank you for helping me
navigate this show as well as life and
your beautiful bear black berry cocktail
and seth meyers i'm not scared you're
scared which is such an amazing book is
now out everywhere grab a copy and enjoy
the read and seth i just i'm so excited
to be doing this with you who knew life
would bring us here i'm so glad it did
it was absolutely a wonderful day to
spend with you thank you so much
[Music]